was man bei alldem verstehen muss es
geht nicht mehr darum zu verhindern dass
menschen mit dem virus zusammenkommen
das ist eine pandemie
sie ist nicht mehr zu stoppen fachleute
gehen nach allem was sie wissen davon
aus dass etwa zwei drittel der deutschen
mit dem virus in kontakt kommen werden
und erkranken
die allermeisten von ihnen 80 prozent
sehr leicht und leicht 20 prozent werden
ärztliche hilfe brauchen und etwa sechs
prozent intensivmedizinische betreuung 6
prozent das klingt nicht nach viel sind
aber mehr als eine million menschen
wenn man jetzt zulässt dass sich die
viren so exponentiell rasant verbreiten
wie sie es von natur aus zu
dann werden sie pflege und kliniken und
ärzte überwältigen
es kommt darauf an den verlauf dieser
kurve zu strecken
dass sich die ansteckungswelle möglichst
weit über das jahr verteilt dann werden
immer noch genauso viele menschen krank
aber eben nach und nach und das
geschehen beruhigt sich und alle können
die maximale hilfe moderner medizin
bekommen
das ist im moment das ziel so wenig wie
möglich ansteckungen jetzt am anfang
und deshalb ist scheinbarer kleinkram
wie händewaschen abstand halten keine
partys machen lebenswichtig nicht nur
für einen selbst sondern vor allem für
die schwächsten in dieser hoffentlich
langen kurve